[Music]
what if I told you you can literally eat
fire yes literally in India pan is a
huge culinary darling that's been around
for centuries
it's a snack usually eaten after a meal
to help with digestion it consists of a
betel leaf that's wrapped around all
kinds of different fillings like nuts
fennel cardamom fruits chocolate or even
meat you can find it anywhere but a
small street food shack in New Delhi is
sparking a revolution
hello you big order for sale
I thought through what our 1950 sequel
America's young people a table got a ps2
memory pass Panama flavors meet up on
hoagie Assad upon chocolate fun but I
squash pawn through tenet fun black
currant bun strawberry pond who's me jo
aapko pasando Gallego co e flavored
allocate or exam factor accuse Camus
meddling all right then but back to the
revolution is sparking recently he had
an idea that would reignite the classic
Indian snack his Shack was famous for
starting man glutamic la vie a long
Milligan look at this
OCP are legato jalaja oh it's calculated
nothing so here he's aware logo appears
who've YouTube or whatsapp readily like
it it's giving us a is calculated in
protein bar target I have a burning
question for you is it safe to eat boy
side-effect Nia the carne or Leticia van
Gogh Sakuraba Jana giveth it though the
eyes open they are confided Hartwell
davara obeah Tino's Ottoman Lee Jackie
APNIC Haghighi Abney parousia Sachiko
Villa Gesell Java - killer ow
the pilot oven glove compartment da da
da da begin a beacon Isaac
better keep speaking money manhandling
you're really bringing on the heat okay
that was a slow burner I was just
warming up okay okay we've already
burned too much time subsided apart
Bonnie look honey a legend in Japan
Kyoto resulted a buscar guru Tom
McCarthy if never calm I got a new doll
ba this is ganguro Tommy hey or am i
sorry again
so there you have it India's hottest
trend go ahead what are your mouth yeah
since the first time it was announced to
the public that we are growing these
there are literally thousands of YouTube
videos of people eating Carolina Reapers
all over the world but I get a kick out
of most of them though it can be
unpleasant it's not a dangerous thing to
eat super hot peppers it's a chemical
reaction your brain perceives as heat so
you will stop doing it
[Music]
I'm smoking at curry I created the
Carolina Reaper I got into breeding
peppers in college but just really was
interested in getting hotter and hotter
peppers once I tried them Guiness
awarded me the world record for the
hottest pepper in November of 2013 to
breed these things I crossed a ghost
pepper with a habanero and what came out
was this evil looking pepper it had
warts all over blisters they call them
and the first time I tasted it it
knocked me to my knees we get our
peppers tested regularly at Winthrop
University by dr. Calaway in the
chemistry lab all peppers are measured
by Scoville heat units which tell you
how hot the pepper is bell peppers have
zero Scoville heat units Tala Pino is
about five thousand a serrano twenty
thousand red habaneros 200,000 ghost
peppers six hundred thousand then you
get to the Carolina Reaper which is one
point five six nine million Scoville
heat units the hottest thing in the
world when you eat the Carolina Reaper
the first sensation you get is sweet and
then all sudden the heat starts going
it's like burning burning burning then
the physiological stuff starts your eyes
will bloodshot they just start tearing
up and watering the skin flushes you
start breathing hard but your metabolism
starts raising up some people say it's
like eating molten lava others will say
it's like licking the Sun to me it's
like eating a charcoal briquette and no
matter what you do you cannot get that
burn out of the back of your mouth I
mean it's crazy a lot of what I do is
creative expression you will look for
traits in one pepper and you look for
traits in another and you try to combine
them and keep both those traits there
are other breeders who are trying to
break our record but we've been holding
unreleased peppers in our back pocket
that are twice as hot or more than the
Carolina Reaper that we
met two Guinness at any time my
perception of what the limits are of how
hot you can greet a pepper has changed
as the science has progressed over the
years just tell me something can't be
done I'm gonna figure out a way to do it
I don't think there is a contradiction
between a simple life and a spicy food
perhaps someone who's living a simple
life needs to have something to spice it
up maybe that works
[Music]
my name is father Richard wolves and I
am a monk of Subiaco abbey which is a
monastery and Subiaco Arkansas after I
graduated from high school I entered the
monastery so I've been 55 years a monk
[Applause]
monk sauce which we produce here at
Subiaco abbey is an avid Earl pepper
sauce we call that monk sauce because
it's monk made anybody who has handled
live in RO peppers knows that you should
not be doing this without a glove on a
good month is a good balance between
prayer and work
[Music]
it ought to be done find out if it's any
good where's the water
I suspect a lot of people have kind of
fanciful ideas about monks and what they
do and they get into the monastery and
they find out that monks are very much
like everybody else I feel very close
connection to the land in this area the
longer that I was here the more I
realized that God got me here because he
knew our to be in a community the
community is a very important thing to
me
[Music]
imagine a river
hard enough to kill you
said to be the home of a powerful
Amazonian water spirit that place is
real and I've been there
it's the shine I think Mishka the
boiling River of the Amazon
[Music]
my name is Anthony Russell and I am a
geothermal scientist and conservationist
as a boy in Lima my grandfather told me
this crazy story about the search for
the lost city of gold
there was a detail on a story about a
river it boiled I certainly imagined it
but never never really dwelled on it it
was just a veto
turns out this place is real so the
boiling River is located in the heart of
the central Peruvian Amazon the hottest
temperature I've measured was over 210
degrees Fahrenheit to put that into
everyday terms the average coffee is
roughly 130 degrees
it's hard to physically imagine that
much hot water you stick your hand in
and you will see second third-degree
burns from a matter of seconds I've seen
a number of animals fall into the boy
river of everything from birds to
reptiles complex organisms like us we
don't do well at those high temperatures
we literally start to cook on the bone
feeling that heat come into you
breathing in this thick hot air where
you can feel the air heating you up
inside your nose you can feel it going
into your lungs you can feel the
presence of your lungs because of the
heat of the air I it still gives me
goosebumps
the true name of the boiling river is
shun I think beach town and that means
according to one of the local shamans
boiled with the heat of the Sun it's
spectacular it's this place is totally
redefined what it means to be sacred for
me I think once you've experienced
something that's truly moved you you
love it and you can't let that go
[Music]
I have been skiing since I was 4 years
old my name is Claudia and I ski over
volcanus
[Music]
I spent most part of a year close to the
mountain when I spent time away from it
I feel nostalgic like if something is
missing to my soul to my life and in
this moment I take my ski and I go up
[Music]
Mount Etna is located on the east coast
of Sicily
is a known as the tallest and active
work on into Europe
the risks joy Mangano Aetna's are the
same of any other mountain
you have to be careful and respect what
is surrounding us
[Music]
the view from the top is unique you can
see the landscape change many times from
cream woods to desert volcanic area all
the lava flow and the cost black powder
is a volcanic sand and its format during
the eruption it's incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Barberini